bajo el lema somos esenciales queremos
la misa cientos de católicos marcharon
por las calles de san francisco para
exigir que reabran las iglesias y para
protestar contra lo que califican como
una discriminación hacia su fe y su vida
espiritual un mensaje que transformaron
en consigna haciéndose eco del
movimiento black life smarter y
resignificando lo bajo el renovado
spiritual life matters o la vida
espiritual importa venimos a protestar
la gran injusticia que se nos está
haciendo de que no nos dejan celebrar la
eucaristía y recibir el cuerpo y sangre
de cristo que es esencial para nosotros
domingo los manifestantes y las
autoridades eclesiásticas consideran que
las restricciones para celebrar misas
impuestas durante la pandemia de
coronavirus representan un trato injusto
hacia la iglesia frente a otros lugares
como peluquerías y tiendas el gobierno
de san francisco ha abierto
todas las actividades todos los negocios
y todo y ha dejado a la iglesia católica
por último no nos permiten sólo permiten
12 personas afuera y ahora permitieron
50 después de marcharse organizaron
misas en varios idiomas respetando la
distancia social y las medidas de
bioseguridad de esta manera los fieles
continúan practicando su fe un derecho
que ven atacado por los funcionarios
locales que según ellos ignoran sus
peticiones durante estos meses de
pandemia la arquidiócesis de san
francisco y autoridades locales
atravesaron momentos de tensión en torno
a las restricciones para las casas de
culto
incluso nancy pelosi presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu entró
en la polémica y le dijo al arzobispo de
san francisco que deberían seguir a la
ciencia